hello I'm gav I'm Dan and I'm excited
and I'm scared we're the Slimmer guys
that's Kentucky believe us back at it
again yeah what's happening I have some
things for you today to try out do you
know what that is this looks like a 556
round this is what we use in the
military sort of standard issue rifle
fires as far as these you would be
correct yeah and that's a 55 grain
bullet and uh today I've got something a
little bit bigger for you to try out and
I'm really excited about this okay so
the grain refers to the weight of the
bullet weight okay yeah these are all
Gonna Knock the snow how do you but I'm
really excited to to see you fire these
really because uh like just like you
said like I'm used to shooting them and
like I do it often uh you're not I'm not
sure your reaction should be pretty
genuine okay ready
his face I'm ready okay
all right you have to chamber it and
then you'll be ready to rock and roll
okay we're ready to rock you're ready to
go ready yep
that's not so bad not so bad yeah you
should be able to tell a difference yeah
yeah between this one and the other one
the grin that you just gave me says so
foreign
[Laughter]
ready we're ready
Child's Play
the first one I was like really like oh
I thought it was I'd be fine so the next
one I was like yeah I'll be fine wasn't
fine and this time I'm like okay I'm
ready for you are you you're ready that
time yeah I was ready safety off
oh
you felt that one I know you felt that
one not that the knocked the air out of
me though
this was the equivalent of someone just
going like
that was the Spartan yeah straight into
your chest there you go have that I can
tell immediately after you shot that one
you were like
yeah yeah
so this one here
is uh very new and this is the 577
Tyrannosaur and uh I think that this one
is gonna kick you harder than anything
else you fired today okay before you
hand it to me
I'm gonna take my shirt off you're like
wait is it oh okay oh to get all the
Rippling yeah I want to get the like
chunky ripples through the body I think
it'd be interesting to see if this is
the beefy one dude yeah this is you're a
red yeah I'm not surprised this might
help with some grip you know like with
the hair always pulls your hair off
this could be the first chest waxing
video with an elephant
all right my friend
here's your safety safety's on okay and
uh you're ready to rock and roll safety
off safety off
oh
you broke it you broke the gun no that's
supposed to happen
that is a patch look at that so uh what
happened when you do that there's this
is the magazine release and it recalled
so hard that your finger came out and
hit it and you released the magazine so
if you're on a safari hunt that'd be
really bad because all your bullets
would fall out it seems like a design
floor I said the same thing they say
that this gun is one of the hardest
recoiling in the world that you could
shoot
whoa oh my goodness
but it's like a display my mom yeah my
arm just was suddenly not in the same
spot
look you about you about yourself in
facing your thumb yeah I like it pulls
me freaking look at the like the
magazine release catch just knocks
straight into my finger there
immediately your bone is moved and
there's like muscle catches up and then
skin is like
it'd be interesting to like film from
behind almost yeah I'd be curious to see
what your shoulder blade is doing yeah I
mean we can do that
foreign
[Laughter]
that was horrible
oh wow oh my gosh it's gonna be so bad
[Music]
it rippled all the way down to my butt
just like that probably ended in your
calf muscles yeah that is absolutely
insane it looks like
someone kicked the chicken
you know on Harry Potter when the uh the
hat starts talking yeah yeah just
forming a face and it's talking yeah
yeah yeah just creasing up
[Music]
looks like right there like it's just
mushed up perfectly I think temporarily
one of your nipples came around the back
nipples
oh there it is
it's massive it's like a joke size if
you can see the rifling in it as well
yeah it's still just breathing fire
afterwards pretty much and then all of
this seems to be like unburned ignitable
fuels yeah
[Laughter]
we'll stick two googly eyes on your back
yeah so my back my back is no longer a
magical hat my nipples back around the
front door so I think that considering
it's such a beefy gun I reckon we should
just shoot some stuff with it sounds
good to me so what's some of your
favorite targets that you'd like to see
at upwards of 80 000 frames a second
glue for sure okay and uh nacho cheese
okay and uh I brought ballistic gel
block yeah I've always wanted to see
some ballistic gel for a start in that
sort of slow-mo that we can get but with
this gun I think it'll be insane it's
I'm really excited to see what that's
going to look like so we went and found
the uh T-Rex round or the Bullet sorry
and you can it's still intact it's gone
through the wood and buried about two
feet in the ground behind there
and I had to dig it out and you can just
see the engaging in the rifling there
around the bands on the outside yeah
it's meant for just deep penetration
just
to go through anything and everything I
did that so we have that and then
that's a 650 grain soft point that's all
lead with a copper jacket okay so you're
going to see quite a difference because
that's just going to zip right through
yeah this is it's going to be like a
bomb going off just so it's going to
break apart and potentially really
bubble out the ballistics a lot yeah
it's going to create a huge wound
Channel and this is uh
so that's a 16 inch block of 10 clear
ballistic gel and I'll set up two blocks
which the solid it's it's going to zip
right through straight through nothing
are you going to shoot the the blocks
and whatnot
uh what do you mean uh I think you you
want to do it you don't want to shoot
them
I think uh no I know you can do it it's
all right you know I've had to it's a
lot of fun I'll volunteers
okay cool thanks right there yeah
okay I'm ready when y'all are
ready
oh
wow
oh wow did you see the the fireball like
the circle that went around it did the
fire go into did you shoot the fire into
the middle of the Block it's lit up from
the inside it's amazing here we go 82
000 frames a second
here it is
what was that happened there
pink what happened
what what is that
there's a single frame what the initial
impact I assume is like just evaporated
whatever the the contact this was and
just flash this is sort of one of those
facts where
the tip of the bullet at that point was
ten times hotter than the surface of the
Sun what if we discovered that this will
now be known as the Kentucky effect yeah
yeah
oh there's like a there's like a cabbage
it's getting sucked into the gel look at
all these ripples like this is
different layers to it look at that
just left that the Fireballs just got
inside there and now it's just burning
propellant in the gel that is collapsing
absolutely insane if this is gas in here
the compression is compressing the gas
and that's what's going to cause it to
go
proper legit explosion pretty much
so bright it's blown it out do you
remember when we did the bangers in the
tank and the compression of the
cavitation re-lit and reignited the gaps
yeah that's exactly what's happened we
sent gas in there and then crushed it so
it went through two 16 inch blocks and
it was like it was it didn't go through
anything no it's different because the
this look did take more punishment than
the second block right so it has
dissipated some energy right right block
right we can work out the deceleration
between the first block and the second
block because it will be a different
speed by the time it comes out right
that was really cool that was excellent
but there yeah
ready
gosh
made the whole thing jump
oh my goodness well most of it's here
look at this though oh God it looks like
old piece came out the side too look
almost looks like fungus like it grew I
guess like each individual one of these
little fins is a piece of it's probably
a piece where it like blew open and then
it seems to have blown open ahead of
where it landed it's the solid core in
the middle there yeah that's the bullet
yeah I can cut it out well I bet it went
in and then got sucked backwards you
think it'll do that sometimes yeah oh
there it is you wanna it's gonna be hot
though
whoa look at that lump of Mel that's a
solid chunk of lead there look is that
this what's this in the middle I can see
is that the jacket is it turned it
inside yeah it literally just mushes
around like that this used to be you can
see the jacket around the outside there
is now in the middle of the bullet you
see that it's just gone inside out so
it's just fold it around fold it it's
just gone like it's gone and just fold
it around it
that's a massive wound Channel when
you're using lead like this the whole
point is to deliver energy yeah and
create a bigger wound Channel rather
than the one we were using it's more for
penetration making it through bone and
muscle or walls you know Boulders pretty
much anything yeah ships an elephant
hiding behind a wall yeah yeah
uh honestly I've never caught the uh if
you're not a soft point before no wow
I've never seen that that's just such a
huge smooth chunk of lead now
oh I just opened like a spewing gas out
it's expensive I got so wide that's gone
like five times the size of it normally
was it turns it into like an opposite
square like it's a square horizontally
and now it's a square like 45 degrees
Offset you can still see the corners of
where it used to be a corner yeah it's
like blue new corners out of the side of
the face it seem like a diamond shape
anytime we watch this it makes me way
more excited oh yeah now I'm really
excited to see that
I only have that um that flash again the
Kentucky effects
oh look at the amount of fire in there
look it's still expanding too it's still
oh that is so bright it blew out the
sensor briefly it's decelerated so much
quicker as soon as it oh yeah look it
almost made it out the end of the block
and it's gonna come back it did look
actually there's like a little puff at
the end
the levitation explosions there was
there wait was it the was it the actual
bullet that went out oh no was it it was
it hit the edge of this I never would
have you said exactly you were exactly
right I've done this a lot clearly I've
I've never I would never expected the
bullet basically made it outside of the
block and then it just signed them back
here
say look it's not even a block anymore
it's just oh it's
um it's like it's simple CGI doesn't it
looks yeah it doesn't look real and look
at the corners swinging around
you turn the Inside Out essentially and
then you filled it with fire so what's
causing what's causing the bullet to
suck back in is it just the elasticity
of them I'm not really sure because
there could be gases just literally
sucking back but it also could just be
the gel itself so that amount of gel
specifically was the perfect yep any
more gel would be unnecessary yeah any
less than the bullet would have gone out
at the end it probably would have just
plopped out into the puddle on the floor
32 inches
maybe the uh because there was still if
you look there's no damage to the end of
that gel right so what it's done is it's
probably squashed that last couple of
inches of gel down to nothing but it
wasn't enough to elastically deform it
and it's just brought it back again so
there's clearly now a lot of gas inside
the passenger to the point where it
actually is like venting like a jet out
the back it's like an exhaust from it
you see that and like my slow-mo camera
I can't pick up anything like that like
that's just yeah I'll see like a quick
flash that's insane that's a whole
nother level yeah I mean it was 82 000
and Frames 82 000 even mine didn't see
anything like that yeah the one that I
use that is so cool and it's also just
absolutely absurd that that is in a
shoulder-fired rifle I mean I mean
really it shouldn't be I would expect
yeah I would expect nothing less though
if I'm going to go trudge out after like
the world's largest animal I guess I
would want something like that I mean it
might even be Overkill it's got setting
up for a Target yeah I've got two
different this is the solid brass round
that's supposed to penetrate then this
is your soft one here look at the
difference in that an incredible
difference so is glue one of your
favorite targets yes I'm really excited
about this glue because it always reacts
in a really weird way yeah I guess so
with your camera it can Webby yeah like
it yeah it tries to hold together you
think he'll come to us the glue to go
make it Maybe
okay here we go
oh my God
look at that I was stood like like 10
feet further back
yeah I definitely hit the little lamb
explosion look at that that and then at
this point you're like I better move I
wonder if we're going to get you turning
around and running away within the shot
we do he's seen that bit
I think does it still hit me yeah he
said I've got glue on the back I've got
glue on your back I think it was that
little chug there a little bit of
spaghetti oh man you can see the bullet
coming in yeah it's so big that you can
just see it plain as day
we can see exactly where you hit it here
oh yeah I definitely pulled to the left
I think
and you see the top go down as it's
stretching From Below yeah
it's D4 oh the top came off
you wouldn't have got a fair effect if
you'd put like a small amount of
dynamite
like a big M80 yeah you'd probably put
like more energy into it yeah I think so
this is actually sped up like 10 times
the actual speed is this
wow yeah it's not moving at all
it just shows you like how quick The
Villa is compared to the aftermath I'm
just gonna put this on my finger and
pick it off later you know when you peel
it off I haven't done that since primary
yeah exactly yes I'm looking forward to
it look at it open it's only like
slightly to the side but because of that
it's meant all the energy has gone that
way and it's just blown it away oh
this has been out here for a while I
don't know this is like a rusty old tin
of cheeses this is like six pounds of
nacho cheese but it's been out here for
a while I don't know listen to that
cheese isn't supposed to sound like it
that's been in the Kentucky heat for a
while if we did like pre-opening Clips
if we did like cold opens that's it
Jesus these ain't supposed to sell them
like that
ready when you are
I took a little extra time
you can see like it goes exactly it made
like a hat shape
I just fully snapped that table in half
I was trying to run but it was too late
I already got hit I already got cheese
son
it's so big that you can see it from
really far away keep it kind of low but
potential look at that oh it just peels
open gosh yeah you're getting some glue
behind yeah so it's already in the berm
yeah
she's
she's explosion look at the Hat it's
made it's made like a perfect like I
think it's just because it hits so low
everything above is still it's like a
rocket so as it's hitting the air it's
spreading it out to the point where this
is all spread because it's all like
misted above it yeah and this is still
like the main meat of the tin
I always I always forget because on all
the footage it just looks like liquid
right just look but it's it's solid oh
yeah
oh
well that was uh definitely the best
looking ballistic gel footage I've ever
seen I have to agree like that's uh that
was really cool I am really glad that we
did that and we had some good sunlight
because yeah we're worried for a while
yeah I was really excited to see what
that was going to look like it was cool
because I knew that ballistic gel would
look good but it's like that rifle and
the round that you fire from it is
probably like the beefiest round you
could yeah so it was like immediately up
to 11. yeah so it looks so cool look at
the amount of damage it's insane you
were very quick to hand over to to Scott
for the firing on this one yeah yeah I
can't talk I didn't fire a single time
I was like Europe where'd he go
I was telling him I was like uh these
rifles you know most people will get
them and they'll take you know one or
two shots and then they're like oh
that's cool I couldn't shoot them
anymore we shot that T-Rex more today
than most people would probably ever
shoot it in their lifetime yeah just
cheese yeah were you feeling it stacked
like the amount of pain each time like I
can feel like after shooting that much I
can feel like like a not a throbbing but
you can tell that something's been
happening there
you can tell
you can tell yeah you could definitely
tell well hopefully you enjoyed that
video once again big thanks to Kentucky
ballistics no problem down the range
make sure you subscribe and you can also
subscribe to us if you like slow mo
we'll see you next time